what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice adding multiple digit
numbers but the point of it isn't just
to get the answer but to understand why
the method we use actually works so
we're going to add 40
762 to 30
473 and you can pause the video and try
to solve it on your own but i encourage
you to watch this one because it's
really about understanding how things
happen
so what i'm going to do is first think
about this in terms of place value so
let me write out my place values let's
see this goes all the way up to the ten
thousands place so let's see ten
thousands
and then we have a thousands
thousands then we have a hundreds i
could write these words out but it's a
little bit faster to write it this way
and then we could have a tens place and
then we could have a ones place i want
to do that in a different color
so then we have a ones place let me make
a table here i'm going to express both
of these numbers in terms of ten
thousands thousands hundreds tens and
ones and then i'm gonna at the same time
use what's sometimes known as the
standard method or the standard
algorithm algorithm's a fancy word for a
system a way of doing something
but let's first represent these numbers
so here i have four ten thousands one
two three four here i have three ten
thousands one two three i'm gonna add
these two together eventually
in both of these numbers i have zero
thousands so i have nothing in this
column right now
here i have seven hundreds one two three
four five six seven here i have four
hundreds
one two three four
then i go to this the tens place here i
have six tens one two three four five
six here i have seven tens one two three
four five six seven and then last but
not least here i have two ones one two
and here i have three ones one two three
now let's just rewrite this number up
here this is just this is four ten
thousands so this is forty thousand i
have zero thousands
right over there and then i have seven
hundreds
seven hundreds i have
six tens
six tens and i have two ones i'm just
rewriting the number i want let me write
the tens in that blue color
so six tens and then two
ones
having trouble switching colors two ones
so there you have it this and this are
just different ways of representing the
same number and then this down here i
have three ten thousands
and then i have zero
thousands
i have four
hundreds here
and then i have was this seven
tens
seven
tens and then i have
three ones
and so now let's add up everything
so i can add it here and then i can also
add up things right over here
so in the standard method we would start
at the lowest place and we'd say okay
two ones plus three ones is equal to
five ones and similarly two ones plus
three ones would be one two three four
five ones fair enough nothing fancy
there
now let's go to the tens place
well in the tens place we have six
tens plus seven tens and the standard
method what you say is that's thirteen
tens but thirteen tens is the same thing
as three tens and one hundred so what
you do is you would regroup you would
say hey look this is three tens
and
one hundred sometimes people say oh
you're carrying the 1. 6 plus 7 is 13
carry the 1 and it seems somewhat
magical but all you're doing is you're
taking 10 of the tens and you're
regrouping it as a hundred it'll be a
little bit clearer here
so we have six one six tens and then we
have seven tens you add them all
together you get one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen tens and all we're doing right
over here is we're saying look this is
equal to
a hundred so let's
let's just convert that into
into
into a hundred right over here let's
just convert that and so what we do is
we just write the 3 in the tens place
and then we add an extra 1 in the
hundreds place and so what are we going
to have in the hundreds place now
and actually let me do it here because
it's a little bit more interesting so i
have 1 2 3 4
six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve hundreds so i
could write them down here one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
and twelve but with the same thing we
don't have a digit for the number 12 in
our traditional number system and so
what i could do is i could take 10 of
these
and i can convert it to a thousand so
i'm going to take 10 of those and give
myself a thousand and we're going to do
the exact same thing over here 1 plus 7
plus 4 is 12.
so you'd write that's 2
hundreds
because this is 12 hundreds that's two
hundreds plus a thousand so we just
regrouped again now in the thousands
place one plus zero plus zero is one
thousand and you see that right over
here you have one thousand and then
finally in the ten thousands place four
ten thousands plus three ten thousands
is seven ten thousands four ten
thousands plus three ten thousands is
one two three four five six seven ten
thousands and so this number is seventy
one thousand
two hundred and thirty
five
seventy 71
so hopefully it all makes sense how
these two things will fit together that
what's going on over here you're not
just magically carrying numbers or
magically regrouping you're just
representing the same number in
different ways